[Music]
okay everyone i'm really excited today
before i jump into this big interview
just giving a heads up that please watch
episode four of season 4 before you
watch this interview we're going to be
talking spoilers
so you don't want to be ruined by that
having said that i'm really excited
because
amanda brugel is with me today aka rita
how you doing today amanda
i'm great how are you i'm doing great so
what i want to ask you about is this
episode 4 because it really leans into
rita's story and people
are really excited to see this and if
you could break down rita's mindset for
me a bit
when she first sees serena and learns
about
her having this baby boy coming because
it seems like moira is like hinting to
rita to like go in there hot and let out
you know all the there but she really
doesn't in a sense so can you kind of
explain maybe what rita is thinking
there
no i mean i think that she still
has a an emotional connection to
the serena joy i i don't know if it's
the healthiest but
rita was trapped in that house with the
waterfords for so
long that there's still uh there's still
some sort of
connection between the two of them and
rita as we've seen is very stoic is very
calm and so i don't know if she's
necessarily as the pop-off
kind of type um and then when she
realizes that a boy is coming
rita as we've learned in the earlier
seasons lost a son
and so and being in the waterford house
all she ever really wanted to do was
have a child so she could take care of
and
help raise and so i think it's really uh
it really guts her in that moment and
brings her right back to gilead and
being trapped
by serena but as serena starts
mentioning in the scene and starts
talking about the fact that we were
friends and she misses a friend i think
rita clocks her intentions
and is like no i'm not getting i'm not
getting
like snagged back into the spider web
again and it has the ability to leave
yeah so do you think that rita then is
kind of fighting
some parts of her that are a little bit
stockholm syndrome with the water
absolutely
a thousand percent and even even the
fact that she
gets out and is free in canada now
there's still stockholm syndrome
that's going on i mean she had ritual
and purpose and
and sort of a routine every day in
gilead and now she's in canada by
herself in an apartment with no family
i think seeing serena joy reminded her
immediately at home whether or not it's
healthy
i don't think so but it's still it still
is home
to her sure and it's so fascinating your
storyline this season and
especially just how now you are in
canada
and i think that your best moment to
date it was a moment where i stood up
and clapped
is when rita sees fred and she hands him
that baby pic is like you deal with your
family it's not my job anymore and
i thank god for that every day when you
what was your reaction you first read
that in the script did you like get
really excited i just was
really excited i'm so happy and the
thing is i know
i know from myself as a fan i wanted to
see her go in
and just tear him apart but i love
what we came up with in the end it was
sort of a
a very very slow simmer just calmly
telling him
that he's that she's clean of him and
she doesn't need him and then the button
of i'll pray for your son
is it's because she doesn't need to
scream and carry on and be crazy she's
releasing him
in a way she's releasing him with more
grace than he handled
his business which i think is the
ultimate insult um
and then also spilling the beans and
betraying serena joy at the same time so
it's a one-two punch but
elegantly i love that and yeah it's
definitely one-two punch and it's cool
that rita does it in like her
own style and it's interesting too
because i think the whole episode just
rounds out masterfully because there's
this last shot
of rita where she's properly setting the
table gilead style but
it is take out sushi she's eating can
you kind of just
tell me how you read that scene what
that kind of how you take that
well the it was the it was then it's the
transition
in the entire arc this season for for
rita because
up until then um she's quite formally
dressed and she's still very formal
but i think in that moment in the
privacy of her own
room eating what she wants being able to
drink a coke being able to
set and and and arrange the table
however she
she wants suddenly she was she was
relearning
freedom in that moment and relearning
independence and so it happens in real
time where you can see what she's doing
by herself
and uh it's like watching someone grow
within seconds and that's
it was it was really satisfying to be
able to play it because i love her so
much
so it felt like a little present for me
as well
hell yeah you could have said it better
and it really hits that way for the
audience i'm so excited to see where
this
rita arc is going to go this whole
season everyone make sure to check out
the handmade sale on hulu
every wednesday thank you so much amanda
brugel for joining me and i hope to talk
to you in the future one day
you're welcome honey have a good day